Greek folk dancing in Scandinavia the
southern Swedish port city of
Helsingborg is hosting a four-day folk
culture festival Greece is represented
here and the Baltic States in fact more
than 250 regions from across Europe are
taking part they dress up in traditional
costumes and perform traditional dances
Europe from for the heart's not
economical not financial that people
bringing together to enjoy to dance to
sing to make music and to show their
culture and to have respect for each
other
this group comes from Shrek's Park in
central Germany they say their costumes
were inspired by the fairytale Little
Red Riding Hood by the Brothers Grimm at
home residents of trach Spock wear these
costumes on local holidays these
costumes were worn by our ancestors my
grandparents and great-grandparents wore
them and now we wear them people
recognize us when we do you wear these
clothes with pride you can stand up and
say we're representing our homeland the
girls and young women wear red after
they marry they switched to green to
show that they're spoken for Berlin
photographer Gregor hohenberg is working
on a book about these costumes
he's been travelling around Germany for
five years meeting various regional and
local groups and has become a real
expert on traditional costumes in the
corner hidden codes or nonverbal
communication in these costumes if you
study the colours the position of the
scarves the tilt of the hats you can
find out whether someone has reached
marrying age whether they're grieving
over a deceased loved one and so forth
father costumes can tell us a lot they
were sort of like the Instagram and
Facebook of their time I saw it as well
Instagram on Facebook man buffoon
because normalizer hohenberg also works
as a fashion photographer and that's how
he sets up some of his shoots here these
are handcrafted works of art a wedding
outfit from lower saxony some of the
costumes look like they come from Asian
regions they're covered with gold
embroidery and glass beads the patterns
even the gloves are perfect it looks
like a Paris Fashion Show effect as with
me what Couture as police cd-roms the
great fashion house's have never shied
away from basing their designs on
traditional European costumes take the
French label Chanel for example these
pieces from their 2015 pre collection
are based on traditional Austrian
designs fashion designers who turned up
at this year's auto-pay autumn might
have been surprised these items look
slightly avant-garde the folks who are
wearing them come from Greenland their
clothes are part of their ethnic
identity
cotton speciate clean on this fact that
our costumes especially the ones that
women wear are completely different no
two are alike the colors and the
patterns and the way they're all made
our traditional the Greenlanders stage a
special performance a lot of visitors
seem surprised that Europe has such a
rich history of traditional costumes
6000 people are taking part in this
festival that's quite a few you
shouldn't forget your traditions life
goes on
but you shouldn't forget where you come
from right I think it's great I don't
find old fashion the tulle that's just
how the folks who attended this year's
folk culture festival see it these
costumes aren't museum pieces they're
worn as part of everyday life in many
parts of Europe and young people are
continuing that tradition
you